(techno music)
(rap beat)
- [Trap House] Okay, there's some beats.
(Beats)
(Laughing)
Hip-hop allows you to be the
voice for the voiceless.
When I met Isaiah, I
didn't know what to expect.
Once I had an opportunity
to communicate with him,
I was like, nah, he can talk.
He can talk.
He has no problem talking.
Let's figure out how we
want to end this song out.
How we want to close it out.
When I think of Isaiah as an artist,
I more-so feel that he's a poet.
He's writing poetry, he's
talking about his experiences.
♫ I don't care what people think of me.
♫ Proud and honored that they carry me.
♫ Jaw gone but I love myself,
like a lion to my family.
♫ Heart big...
The first thing that Isaiah
and I did was Oxygen to Fly.
He wrote it, I was the voice.
It's a challenge to be
someone else's voice,
but Isaiah has so many
things that he wants to say,
we find a way to make it work.
(Laughing)
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Next we can work on the second verse.
Before I worked with Isaiah,
I had a heavy presence
in the local scene as far as rap music
as well as some community work.
- [Music Director] All right,
we're going to take it from the top, ok.
- [Trap House] We were
able to come together and
kind of amplify our message and that's
just that you shouldn't stand to the side
and do nothing if you're fully
capable of doing something.
I brought out a special guest tonight man,
his name is Isaiah the Rapper.
Ya'll do me a favor and make
some noise for my boy Isaiah.
(Cheering)
(Soulful music)
(Rapping music)